foreign
the privileged fall
that's code don't forget it
the CIA have a list of enemies they
consider Untouchable take a look at that
file Miro lundell notorious human
trafficking Kingpin basically
Untouchable so is he
wow
can I come in
I'm uh no I don't know you what do you
want to know work for the D.A you watch
enough guilty people walk free and
eventually you want to go out there and
take care of them yourself
the collective of getting close to
finding us what they're collected dead
dead
found him I'll send some guys
we speak for the innocent judge jury and
executioner
let's make him fall
thank you
we have a problem
that's well done
we're in a league of a home
you blew up my house Sam
it happens